foreign
[Music]
we're not there the car exploded
come get the girls I have to stay here
with Woodrow another chauffeur I'm the
grandfather where are you asteroid City
Farm Road 6 Mile 75
your star gazers and Space Cadets each
year we celebrate asteroid day
commemorating September 23rd 3007 BC
when the Arid Plains meteorite made
Earth impact
oh
it's Kimberly Toledo that's Mitch
Campbell you're very good in the one
about the in the brothel who is
amnesian making a pediatrician you're
very honestly maybe my favorite
character ever I don't know why nobody
else liked it
what are those pulses indicate what oh
the beeps and blips we don't know some
of our information about outer space May
no longer be completely accurate anyway
there's still only nine planets in the
solar system as far as we know Billy
except now there's an alien
I don't know
I don't like the way that guy looked at
us the alien how did he look like we're
doomed
maybe we are I've just informed the
president how long can they keep us an
asteroid City legally the world will
never be the same that's an alien doing
jumping jacks that's an alien at a top
hat what's out there the meaning of life
maybe there is one are you married I'm a
widower but don't tell my kids you're
saying her mother died three weeks ago
let's say she's in heaven which doesn't
exist for me of course but you're
Episcopalian in my loneliness I learned
to give complete and unquestioning Faith
to the people I love I don't know if
that includes you but it included my
daughter and your four children
sometimes I think I feel more at home
outside the Earth's atmosphere oh wow
me too they're strange aren't they
they're children
compared to normal people yes that's
correct it's true
going so fast
scene you want to see it
did I say yes you didn't say anything I
meant yes my mouth didn't speak
foreign
[Music]